would you rather have a free house
completely free I just give it you as a
gift or me teach you how to get it most
people will say just give me a house let
me tell you something if you know how to
get it you can do it again and again and
again and again also most people say I
just run to have a free house I was in
hide Park London trying to give away a
free house and everyone was walking past
me I was said excuse me would you be
interested and they go no thanks mindset
is everything knowledge is everything
come spend a day with me at the crash
course let me show you how to actually
get one yourself so you can build it up
build it up build it up let's go one
pound one pound